get an idea and go do something about it
like expect it to suck expect it to have
a million mistakes don't judge yourself
for how well you know the thing does but
just you just start because you came up
with the idea and so trust in your ideas
because your best ideas are often the
ones that don't make sense for someone
like you to do and so I've been trying
to shortcut my brain out of the equation
which might sound really weird I don't
know I don't know if anybody else does
that but um yeah my brain keeps me small
and I want to play big if we rely too
much on our brain I think what we do is
we end up relying so much on our brain
and not so much on our heart because
your heart has this big idea right it
has this dream it wants to do something
it wants to create it wants to impact
but then our mind really tells us like
no no no stop no you can't do that that
doesn't make sense and then what do we
want to do we want to sit there and
think our way through it right we want
to perfect it and then you know as Ed
mylett says you know Perfection is the
enemy of execution because we can sit
there and think our way through it but
at the end of the day what I personally
end up with is just this analysis
paralysis where you think so much much
and you overthink that you end up just
doing nothing and how many of us really
just end up doing nothing in the end so
you know what you got an idea just take
action just do it you know do it and
you'll learn and course correct and
pivot when you need to but you just do
it
all right believe Nation we are starting
a new q a show I'm super excited taking
your questions and I have a special
guest with me mindset Mary she's in my
thought leadership Mastermind she's a
mindset coach and she's going to help
answer some of these questions for us
today anything you want to add to that
Mary absolutely thank you Evan for
having me this is super exciting and I'm
I'm ready when you are all right
question number one and we'll let Mary
answer them first and then I'll I'll uh
yeah we'll let you answer them first
we'll be fine then I'll I'll Jive off of
what you said and see if I agree or
completely disagree with what you said
we'll see we'll see how it goes question
number one is how to overcome the fear
of starting yes the sheriff starting I
think most of us that I've tried
something new or venturing Into A New
Path have that initial fear of starting
so I think for me as a mindset coach and
as someone who's gone through the same
experience I think you really have to
break down like what is it that you're
actually afraid of like are you as a the
fear of failing the fear of starting
small like what is it that you're really
really afraid of if you were to start
and
um I think that like we all sort of have
these two voices in our heads right like
there's like the inner critic that'll
tell us about everything that could go
wrong if we were to start and then we
have like The Advocate who's a dreamer
who tells you what's possible it's it
always comes down to who you're focusing
on the most right whatever you focus on
most will always prevail
so um I think that if you actually want
to start uh you really do have to quiet
the inner critic because we have to
change the way we're looking at things
we have to change our questions I need
we could be afraid of starting but what
about the fear of never starting at all
right and where is that gonna get you
right
um what would that do for you for your
future where would you be or where
wouldn't you be at so I think sometimes
the best thing that we can do to
ourselves is to flip the script and
really you know bring into existence the
absolute opposite of what it is that we
are thinking to give our minds that
opportunity to explore a different
thought because you know as we have
different thoughts so we start to
cultivate different emotions and it will
lead to different behaviors and actions
so I think like if you can play your own
Devil's Advocate if we're so good at
looking at what's wrong then maybe we
should start getting good at looking at
what's right
I used to look at the you know I think
the maybe the first
how old am I 43 started my first
business at 19 real business and I think
for the first 20 or so years I really
lived through that lens of future regret
like whenever I didn't know
how it turned out I was afraid of doing
something I would use that model of okay
imagine I'm on my deathbed and looking
back and like I wish I had started this
thing and trying to make it so painful
that it forces me to take action right
like the rocking chair test you're
you're in an old age home you're at the
end of your life and like now you
actually can't do it it's too late and
then giving yourself advice back to
today and I use that for
20 years and it really really helped me
the shift that I've made in the past
four years is trying to
shortcut my brain out of the equation
and I don't know if anybody else is is
talking about this or doing this but
doing the regret test for me
means that you have to catch it and so
in this person with their question they
they caught it right so they caught that
they're afraid but I think a lot of
times we don't even catch that we're
afraid we just automatically say no to
our ideas we just see that thing and
come up with some reason why we can't do
it you know I'm too old I'm too young
I'm too I'm too whatever
and when you can go through the mental
exercise to then say okay well I'm
afraid and so what would I you know my
85 year old self tell me I think that
definitely helps when you catch it and
when you don't catch it then what do you
do and so the past four years what I
really focused on is
one the fact that I got the idea means I
have to do it so just because I came up
with the idea means I'm gonna get
started on it
and so I want to shortcut my brain out
of the equation because your brain's
designed to keep you safe your brains
designed to keep you small your brains
designed to keep you protected and so
your brain is not usually the one coming
up with these amazing things to do with
like your heart wants to go and change
the world and your brain tells you you
can't do that who do you think you are
to be able to do that
and so I want to try to show up my brain
out of the equation so the idea of just
going from idea to action gets me to
just go and do it because I came up with
it so even this even this show I came up
with a show idea on Tuesday where this
is a Friday right now as we're recording
this I came up with the show ID on the
Tuesday I messaged Mary on Tuesday I
think so yeah Wednesday I don't even
know Tuesday and said Mary what are you
doing Friday at three o'clock Eastern
and she's like I'm free what do you want
to do I said we're going to do a show
and we're gonna have these questions and
and over the past few days we've been
collecting questions and and now we're
here doing the show and I'm not
overthinking it you know because I think
a lot of times what I used to do would
have said okay so who's my guess going
to be and what are the questions going
to be and how are we going to set this
up and all of these what ifs and then
it'd be three months later and you like
still haven't done the thing
and so I In My Own Worst Enemy or have
been and so I just want to cut all that
out and just get started and maybe maybe
this q a show has a really short shelf
life or maybe this is like the only
thing I end up doing for the rest of my
life I don't know at least for me you
can't think your way through that
problem you just have to start doing it
and see what happens and so the thing
that's helped me through this of getting
started is just
get an idea and go and go do something
about it like expect it to suck expect
it to have a million mistakes don't
judge yourself for how well you know the
thing does but just you just start
because you came up with the idea until
trust in your ideas because your best
ideas are often the ones that don't make
sense
for someone like you to do
uh and so I've been trying to shortcut
my brain out of the equation which might
sound really weird I don't know I don't
know if anybody else does that but um
yeah my brain keeps me small and I want
to play Big I love that Evan I love that
I think that that's amazing because I
think that if we rely too much on our
brain I think what we do is we end up
relying so much on our brain and not so
much on our heart because your heart has
this big idea right it has this dream it
wants to do something was it wants to
create it wants to impact but then our
mind really tells us like no no no stop
no you can't do that that doesn't make
sense and then what do we want to do we
want to sit there and think our way
through it right we want to perfect it
and then you know as Ed mylett says you
know Perfection is the enemy of
execution because we can sit there and
think our way through it but at the end
of the day what I personally end up with
is just this analysis paralysis where
you think so much and you overthink that
you end up just doing nothing and how
many of us really just end up doing
nothing in the end right so you know
what you got an idea just take action
just do it you know do it and you'll
learn and course correct and pivot when
you need to but you just do it that's
what I was missing right I spent so much
time learning studying audibles podcasts
certifications and it's like more more
more well yeah guess what there is an
ocean of information out there but that
information is completely useless if you
end up doing nothing with it other than
obtaining more of it right like when we
do that we almost we're almost like
excusing ourselves from taking action
because we're saying no no we need to do
this first but you know what no at some
point you need to just stop
and take some action and learn from that
like it really has to be a balance and I
think so many of us end up just living
in all this information and and never
really doing anything with it which
means it's useless if you haven't
applied it you haven't like used it in
any form then that time you spent
acquiring it is time wasted and that's
when I learned the hard way well we all
learned the hard way you know and
hopefully we get uh coaches and people
to help us and mentors so that we make
it a little bit easier on ourselves the
next time through
um the other thing with with that is I
come up with trigger words so scary
difficult hard or my trigger words where
if I think it if I say it if I feel it
if I write it if I text it yeah scary
difficult or hard then I have to do it
just because yeah so the fact that this
question says you know that they're
afraid of starting and it's a scary
difficult hard if that was a reason for
me to not do something then I have to do
it just because because I want to be the
person who does scary difficult hard
things because my my goals my dreams are
on the other side of doing scary
difficult and hard yes and so we've
accepted these reasons for not taking
action so if if I was this person and
and the trigger word here would be fear
so you want to be the person who does
the things that you are afraid of so
anytime fear is the reason now of course
don't go jumping out of an airplane with
no parachute you know like these are
that's that's just stupid right but
allowing fear to run your life means you
will never have a great life
and so the good news is I mean the bad
news is we're always playing small and
our brain is always convincing us why we
can't do things the good news is the
reason that our brain gives us is
usually the same reason over and over
and over again
that's true and so if you can catch it
right so if you were a historically
always wanting to learn learn learn and
never do maybe the story is
um I don't know enough you know I don't
know enough yet to get started I don't
know enough to do this okay great so now
anytime you think feel say I don't know
enough now you have to go off and do it
just because and so the bad news is the
brain is trying to talk us down from the
things but the good news is it's the
same story every time and so if you can
figure out what are those patterns or
triggers for you then the next time it
comes up because that's going to keep
coming up then because you thought it
said it texted it uh now you have to go
off and do that thing
oh just because that's so good Evan and
you know what it's almost like if you
have that fear
maybe you should ask it or ask yourself
what is this fear trying to teach me
like what is it trying to tell me about
myself maybe the fear is just there as a
warning sign right just like on your
dashboard of your of your car you know
there's a signal that comes up you need
to pay attention to it what is it that
you need to give yourself to overcome
that fear right so if we can try to
almost befriend the negative emotions
and use them as teachers trying to warn
us from things that you know that are
the things that are it was it's just try
to protect us right so what are you
trying to tell me and how do I fix that
if we can befriend our fears I think we
can develop a better relationship with
those negative emotions
it make well it makes me like the way
you said that makes you want to give it
a name you know like my fear is Susan
hey Susan thank you for being here Susan
you know I wanna I wanna befriend Susan
isn't yeah absolutely yeah I think that
that makes sense
all right good next question that came
in was why is change hard
yeah why is change hard million dollar
question I think change is hard because
like we're just creatures of comfort we
like our routines we like stability we
like predictability and and when you're
telling us or telling me I need to
change it means that you're asking me
Twinkle bro right you're asking me to
get outside of my comfort zone and
experience the unknown the newness
things that are difficult things that
I'm not good at doing so I think that
you know when when when we need to
change it's hard because we just don't
have it dialed in right it's asking us
to change the way where we schedule
ourselves it might be asking the way you
were thinking asking us to get in other
organizations or different circles meet
different people so I think it's just
it's hard because it's not known it's
scary we're not familiar with it but it
doesn't have to be hard I think if we're
able to use change as not something
that's big and scary but something think
that's that you approach it with more
newness and curiosity and possibility I
think if you can just change the way you
connect with uh change if you change the
way you connect with change I think that
you know I think that it will change the
way you actually viewing the change
itself so I think like getting out of
our comfort zone taking those risks can
be scary at first but it's just like a
muscle right like you have to train it
if you're not training yourself and
getting into the unknown and meeting new
people and doing difficult scary
difficult and hard things if you're not
training that muscle it's going to
atrophy so it's like okay change is a
constant the only constant is change we
know that as a fact so let's just get
better at change right
I think I think a big problem here is
identity so if you've been doing
something for long enough you become
that person yeah and so when you want to
inject something new it requires you a
lot of times to change your identity
because when you start something new
here's what's going to happen you're
going to suck at that thing true and we
don't like sucking at things
and so when you start something new
you're going to start a podcast start a
book start a coaching business start a
new job start a relationship start or
whatever you're gonna do something
completely different that's in your
heart but but you've never done it
before and someone like you right that's
an identity someone like you can't do
this thing
and then you try it you know going going
back to our last question now you try
something and you and you take it and
then you suck you fall off the bike
you you stumble on camera and we don't
like that feeling and what we do is we
make we make that feeling mean that we
suck the fact that you suck at doing
something but then we internalize for
our identity that we suck as a human
yeah and that's where we have a hard
time I think differentiating that the
fact that you suck at something doesn't
mean that you suck as a human it's
actually the opposite the fact you're
willing to try that thing means that
you're amazing and it's just a skill set
that you can learn and develop and get
better at I have two things that I would
suggest to in addition to what what you
shared the first is just expect to suck
expect to suck at the beginning expect
you're going to burn your first you know
meal that you try to make your barbecue
is not going to work you know your
lawnmower is going to break down your
camera is going to shut off and overheat
like just expect a sec and it removes
the the burden and the stress of
uh of getting started because if you
expect to be good then when you don't
end up being good
you don't want to do it again I think I
think um the problem is people have good
taste like you know what Great Looks
like most people know what Great Looks
like if you're going to start a podcast
or interview Channel you know what great
looks like you can look to you said Ed
my Ladd or Joe Rogan or Tim Ferriss or
Mel Robbins or and you know what Great
Looks like Oprah Winfrey awesome
and you don't expect to be great you
don't expect to be Ed mylett out of the
first gate right that that that's not
rational but you also don't expect to
suck you know he's like I'm I kind of
know what good questions are and I kind
of know how this stuff works and if Ed
mylett is like an A-Plus I'm like a b a
b minus I think I could I think I could
you know I'll be okay and then you do
your first one and it just sucks you
know like you're nervous and it's you
have no idea what you're doing and you
you blank out and then an hour later
it's like I should have said this you
know when the camera stopped rolling
and so you don't expect to be an F you
expect to be a b right
but you know what an A plus looks like
and so that's where a lot of people quit
they stop making a change because they
had higher expectations of themselves
than what they were able to produce and
it's just too much expectations in the
short run where you can get to a b
pretty quickly but you're gonna probably
start off as an F so just expect to suck
at the beginning so whenever I do
anything
I just expect a suck at the start and
give myself permission to fail all over
the place and amazing
and so that differentiation between the
fact that you suck at a skill
does not mean that you suck as a human
and if you can actually separate those
things out I'm awesome for trying this
thing and failing
not I suck because I failed this thing
yeah I love that Evan I love that and
you're right I think part of it is we've
lost the ability to delay our
gratification right like we want to be
great at the beginning from the
beginning or at least we want to see
results and we want to see them quickly
you know when you're thinking about you
know the big names I'm sure they didn't
have the best videos when they first got
started right like that's a skill and
that's a skill you develop with time and
repetition so I think that that's like
because we tend to see the end result
right we see them when they're big and
famous and they're doing big things with
big impact but what we're not seeing is
how did it all start and what did they
have to do right there's always hard
work any successful person has done hard
work right you don't just get successful
on your own I mean that title is earned
through hard work and smart work and
surrounding yourself with the right
people I think we have to have realistic
expectations of ourselves you're right
we're expecting to be a b but why should
I be a b if I haven't gone through CD E
and F right if I haven't received those
grades I should actually be expecting an
f and then expecting that I will get
better with time right but it's true we
skip a lot of the steps because we have
an inability or a difficulty in delaying
the gratification and that's partly
because you know the accessibility of
social media and just seeing what people
are capable of achieving but what we're
not seeing is you know the iceberg we're
not seeing what's beneath that Iceberg
and what it took to you know what what
it took to get to where they are so I
think that that's a big reason why
sometimes people feel like they're so
much further away from that goal than
they actually are because we create such
a distance between where we are and
where we want to be that we actually
keep ourselves held back and then we
don't take that action right going back
to that first question and and we keep
ourselves far you know far away from
that goal and and I think that that's
that's the difficult part and if we want
to get closer to that goal we have to
start taking some form of action even if
it's small action I think at the end of
the day if you have a big dream you
gotta stay connected to that dream by
doing something that's going to get you
closer even if it's just a millimeter
something every day that gets you closer
to that tree so we have to be touching
those dreams every single day
consistently
you know listening to you talk
um a little alarm bell went off in my
head and maybe maybe I'm again like just
a super weird deck but one of the things
that I've really focused on is yeah
changing what I align gratification to
so instead of it being like delayed
gratifications on the result that you
hope to get where I'm much more aligned
to the process and willingness to show
up so this show that we're doing here
this is the gratification right here for
me like how well the show does I don't
know maybe it gets a million views maybe
it gets 14 views maybe people say oh my
God I love you guys many people say that
was a dumbest idea of all time I don't
care right like it's it's that this that
I came up with the idea on Tuesday or
whatever and then message you and then
here we are doing it and that's the
gratification for me that's the reward
for me like my dopamine is going off
that we made this happen and then and
then whatever happens with the video
happens with the video and and we'll use
that information and make better videos
and do I continue the series or not but
I tie my gratification to trying the new
thing as opposed to the result that I
get that that's so good tying it to I
feel like you tie your gratification to
the fact that you said you were gonna do
something and you did it and in doing it
you were falling in love with the
process of doing it and you're enjoying
it you're not tying yourself you're not
tying your happiness your gratification
to the outcome of it doing the video
doing well getting a lot of viewers that
doesn't even matter because you love
doing it right and I think also to add
to that I think I would also type
gratification to your intentions like
what's your intention for the show why
are you doing it who are you serving are
you intending to serve others are you
intending to do good are you intending
to teach tie your gratification to your
intention to do good to show up and be
there for people like I think if the
more we can Tire our gratification to
things that we can control that I think
the happier that we can be on our on our
insides right because we're doing things
out of love of doing them and not out of
viewership likes whatever it may be like
like don't even look there and I think
that the most successful people are are
successful because not because they
drank their feet doing the thing it's
because they actually immerse themselves
and loved it right and that's why we
gravitate to those people because they
just they operated a whole different
frequency and you know when you're in
your zone or you're in your element you
know it but also everybody around you
knows it I think it's where a lot of
achievers fall into that trap of you
have this goal and a stealing thing that
matters hitting that goal and then you
hit the goal and then like three seconds
of euphoria and then like oh is that it
like what do I do now you meet the next
goal but if you actually enjoyed the
thing and people ask me why don't like
how have you dealt with burnout on your
YouTube channel yeah because all these
creators talk about burnout right now
it's like burnout what's that well I
mean I I definitely had burnout from the
stuff but not like if you made me an
accountant if you have to look at
paperwork I'm gonna burn out in 18
minutes
but making videos and helping
entrepreneurs into your word of like the
intention and service I've been doing
this for 14 years now
we haven't missed an upload in a decade
probably
because this is it's not this doesn't
work for me being here doing this this
doesn't work this is fun like this is
awesome
and so I think if you are only tied to
the results of course I care about
results of course I want to grow of
course I want to have an impact of
course but it's not the main driver
where I think if that's all and that's
what a lot of achievers are only focused
on the end result but then they're not
happy as they go through it where the
process becomes even more important that
you love it and you're having fun doing
it because otherwise that's the path of
burning out if you don't love the thing
that you're waking up every day to do
you will burn out pretty quickly but if
you love it then it never feels like
you're going to work it's like I can't
wait to go off and do this like I see
this in my calendar I'm going to talk to
mindset Mary this afternoon we're going
to answer this is great you know like
look at the stuff in your calendar does
it get you amped up and you're excited
to do it or it's like oh man I don't
want to do this stupid thing right like
if that was your life every day
you have to switch
you have to switch that was my life
every day waking up to a job that was
stable and secure I you know not
challenging because I already knew
everything it was just mundane right and
and just feeling like I'm not I don't
have something to look forward to when
it comes to my career and it's you wake
up enough days like that then I think
that you know the discomfort that's
associating with not changing far
exceeds the discomfort that's going to
be associated with me changing
everything to start pursuing what I want
and what I love I think it's like
because we're a creatures of comfort and
we're always looking to what's
comfortable the path of least resistance
your discomfort level half really has to
be up here in order to be able to say
you know what enough of this I'm not I'm
not living another day in this way I
want to feel inspired I want to feel
like I have a purpose I want to help
other people and when you start living
more out of your heart and less out of
your head I think that that's when magic
begins to happen for you but you have to
leave with that attention and like to
your to your words you have to be
passionate you have to love what it is
that you do because if you don't other
people will just beat you right to it
right like you can't compete with people
that love it more than you like you you
can't expect to be competing at their
level you really need to love it you
know authentically all right good next
one next question I'm kidding oh it's
great uh how to deal with judgment what
do you think mindset Mary how do we deal
with judgments judgment okay judgment is
interesting right because first of all
there's
you're judging yourself
and you're or you're dealing with others
judging you so sometimes when we're
working with others judging us sometimes
it's not even their judgment of us it's
what we think they think they think of
us right there's like two parts of you
like there's the part that's
introspective and then the part that's
always looking outwardly so I think that
if you can really cultivate like your
self-belief in yourself your self-worth
your self-confidence when you start to
live your life in a way you whereby like
the only opinion that matters is the
opinion that you hold of yourself I
think that that's when you start
developing the armor and the superpower
to let go of judgment because like the
thing is
everyone's gonna judge you people are
gonna judge you all the time because we
all have different life experiences
right we have different values and
belief systems and if you're doing
something that goes against someone's
values or belief system they're going to
judge you and I think we have to always
remember like not to take those
judgments personal because very often
you know like if I'm doing something or
if I'm achieving if I'm creating and I'm
and it's and someone else isn't I'm
almost like holding up a mirror to them
and to show them what their insecurities
are so I think when it comes to like
judgment I think you have to accept the
fact that it's always going to be there
and you really just have to focus on
growing yourself and growing your own
self-worth so that it doesn't affect you
the way it would had you not had that
self-confidence and self-belief and
conviction and what it is that you're
doing right because the judgment's not
gonna go away I think it's just a fact
of life and the other thing is like
judging ourselves like you know I've
judged myself you know like if I'm doing
something or if I'm pursuing something
I'm thinking like oh my God this doesn't
make me a good parent oh I'm spending
too much time doing this I'm studying
I'm neglecting my kids I'm like and
we're constantly
um trying to judge ourselves when we
really should be like having more
self-compassion with ourselves like oh
my gosh I'm doing this I'm creating that
you know I'm doing more I'm giving more
um and and like very rarely do we
celebrate ourselves for the things that
we are doing and very often do we
continue to focus on the things that
we're not doing right what are your
thoughts Evan well you said believe a
lot in there which I love you know this
is why I think I think it's why I
believe is the world's biggest problem
because people don't believe in
themselves is what I wake up trying to
solve for myself and and others as well
where you care about other people's
opinions so much because you need their
affirmations yeah
because you don't love yourself enough
like ultimately that's what it comes
down to it's like I care what these
people say because if they're not saying
good things about me the voice inside my
own head isn't very good and I need
their outside perspective uh to make me
feel good where if you can switch what
you tie your reward system to just the
gratification to instead of the result
or instead of somebody else saying I did
a good job to the process and the effort
that you're putting in when you can tie
your self-identity your self-worth to
the effort that you're putting in every
day yeah as opposed to what ended up
happening or what other people are
saying about you
that's when things start to really
change so I am proud of myself for
getting this show off the ground you
know in a couple days and here we are
right again how well it does if the
comments say I love I love Evan uh I
love Mary or they say I hate Evan I love
Mary you know whatever great you know I
will use it as feedback like how could I
use that to get better but my my sense
of self isn't impacted by somebody
leaving a comment positive or negative
yeah right we we tend to only look at
the negative ones like somebody called
you ugly or somebody said you suck on
camera or somebody said whatever the
thing you made was terrible and that's
what hurts us
but even the positive ones if you let
that hit you too hard then we become
dependent on like you're only going to
do it if you get that positive feedback
loop and that's dangerous as well
because it's basically another human
giving you your self-worth instead of
you giving yourself the self-worth and
so trying to tie your identity to are
you proud of how you showed up today I
have the pillow test at night so before
I hit my head on the pillow I ask myself
am I proud of the effort that I put in
today the effort and some days I've
achieved amazing things some days
I sucked you know like I could barely
get anything off maybe I had no sleep
maybe I had chaos happen around that
like I got none of the things on my
checklist done but I'm still proud of
how I showed up and reacted to the day
that that showed up for me I think when
you can shift your identity to that it
really helps
um and then you you made a good point
about looking backwards for yourself and
like I should have done this I should
have done that and the thing that was
coming to my mind there was I will just
remind myself and other people when
they're asking these questions that just
tell yourself that you did the best you
could with what you had
like at that moment in time I've made
tons of mistakes in my past there's no
point in me spending the next 10 years
thinking about the last 10 years and all
my screw-ups and what I should have done
differently and could have done better
and yes you know if you took me back
five years ten years whatever 19 year
old I've been starting this business
holy cow all the mistakes like I would
love to sit there as 43 year old Evan
and just really help 19 year 11 and tell
them what's up to avoid all of the
things that he's about to screw up on
you know in life and business
but I can't and so 19011 did the best
city code with what he had
and I'm smarter now and I'll make better
decisions going forward and so how do
you unburden yourself like people are
walking around with all of these
self-judgments on them of what they
should have been doing to unburden
yourself like you did the best you could
with what you had at the time
and you're smarter now and you're
stronger now and you can decide now to
take a different path if you want to so
good Evan yeah I I absolutely agree I
think it's a way to kind of just let go
of the past and move forward because I
always use the analogy of like you know
all the things that weigh me down you
know people places things whatever it
may be in my past it's as if I'm trying
to drive my car and my car is my life
and I'm driving it Forward while looking
in the rear view right so what happens
when all you do is keep looking in the
rear view
you can't move forward right you're
gonna have an accident you can't steer
your life forward if all you do is look
backward and I think I like that idea
just say that she did too best you could
and then with what you had that's it
it's done because if thinking about it
and
um you know ruminating over these
thoughts it isn't helping you move
forward in your life right it's not
helping you in your present it's not
helping you in your future it's not
taking you to your goals then we're just
wasting our time
right and I think at the end of the day
that's where I feel like there needs to
be more self-compassion and
self-acceptance
which goes to what you said you know you
did the best you could with what you had
you know and I think that we just need
to kind of move forward it's kind of
like what you said like you know taking
your brain out of the equation and just
doing it this is sort of something very
similar you know you gotta just close
that chapter and start a new one that
was such a huge unlock and I don't know
where it came from because I talked to
all sorts of people giving me guidance
and advice and psychologists and all
sorts of people and it's like you know
what I'm just gonna I have an idea trust
the idea is good
and do something on the idea it sounds
simple and it is pretty simple and and
as soon as your brain gets in the way
then that's when all the chaos starts to
to happen exactly yeah because because
Simplicity is always on the other side
of you know complexity like we can
everybody can make anything complicated
right but it takes a genius to just make
it simple because when it's simple it's
executable the next question comes in
from the real Doctor oh I feel blessed
to have survived and thrived through all
kinds of drama debt disease depression
and of course the huge one divorce I've
discovered that I could desire decide to
find design and deliver it's a lot of
these to myself a life of Distinction
and Destiny she's really in on all the
D's even drama debt disease depression
she is she is loving the D's here uh she
sees like a Wordsmith okay how do I
create the message to help other
professional women especially those in
healthcare yeah Dr o has gone through a
lot a lot in life like you can tell by
just the way she's worded and afforded
for her question and everything that's
transpired
um I think that you know if what I
understand from that question is she's
really just asking like
how do I connect with my target audience
so she has been through all of that and
she's done the work to find her way out
and now all she wants to do is turn back
around and bring everybody with her
right because she has found the light at
the end of that long dark up that
she walked down
and I think that this is something that
most entrepreneurs are trying to figure
out which is like how do I connect with
my audience
and I think like for me I what I've done
personally is first of all you know I
think if you want to connect with your
audience you have you had to have walked
in their shoes and understand their pain
points and their struggles and she's
working with people in healthcare you
know people who are you know
overburdened they're struggling they're
you know they've got so much going on
they've sacrificed so much they have
high stress jobs and she gets it right
like she's lived it I think that if you
want to be able to connect with your
audience you have to tell them your
story
you have to connect with them in that
their your story is also their story and
you have to be able to show them your
process your way you know what your
realizations were what were your
struggles and what were your victories
how did you get out of them I think you
have to be able to connect with that
audience and show them how you got out
so that they're able to understand what
is your purpose why do you want to help
them and how does you helping them fix
their problems I think you have to be
able to connect your purpose to their
solution and I think until people see
that I told people could resonate that
you understand me you get me you
understand what I'm going through and
you're showing me how you're going to
get me out of it until you can do that I
don't think it's possible to be able to
get someone to follow your path or get
get your assistance so that's that's
where I'm coming from in the sense that
how do you connect with someone who
you're trying to serve like you're
targeting that person and I think yeah
you have to share you have to be
vulnerable purple so that they can feel
vulnerable and believe that they you
believe oh that you actually can help
them right because how many times do you
get hit up a day with DMS and people
just like hey do you need this click
funnels you know uh coaching people are
hitting you up a video editing every
single day but you know what you're
kidding me up but you don't know me you
don't know what I need you really have
to be able to First establish and
nurture a connection whether that's like
you know putting out free content it's
like how are you connecting with your
audience where is your audience connect
with them where they are
and start giving them value start
sharing your story let them get to know
you you know sometimes you know if
you're a public figure people feel like
they know you right you don't know them
but they know you why because you've
shared so many parts of yourself that
most aren't willing to share so it's not
a surface level I know Evan Carmichael
it's a deeper level like I know his
story I know his struggles I know his
fears I know his limiting beliefs like I
know so much about him and guess what I
relate to so much of that it resonates
with me now I'm gonna start building
connection and trust with that person
right but a lot of people are just not
willing to be vulnerable enough to let
people get to know them
and that creates a struggle and a hurdle
for them to be able to actually reach
the target audience because at the end
of the day I only resonate with people
who I feel like are being honest and
truthful to their core authentic to
their Court I understand their
intentions I'd understand their mission
and I'm on board right so that's that's
kind of a starting point and look at how
she worded this question you can tell
that she spent a lot of time thinking
about this question and she spent a lot
of time thinking about this in her in
her mind as well about trying to build
this brand so some people when they
write in questions it's totally spur of
the moment you know they they haven't
spent a ton of time thinking there's
typos in the in it you know but then you
look at yeah real doctor oh here it's
like drama debt disease depression
divorce desire decide to find design
deliver distinction Destiny he's like
here's somebody who has spent I've never
seen so many d words in one question and
and that's not just an in the moment
thing like she's been thinking about
this probably for years now at this
point and so people when they have a big
desire to serve and they've been
thinking about it for a long time the
how now starts to get impossible like
there's so many different houses where
do I start how do I do this how do we do
that how do we and and there's infinite
numbers of hows because whatever path
you take that then opens up a door to a
million other cow doors right it's like
I'm going to start a YouTube channel oh
great that's one path okay but then you
open up that door like well how do I get
the camera and how do I get the
microphone and then how do I thumbnail
and how do I title and how do I film and
do I need a team and how do I hire a
team and then and then it's just this
infinite possibilities of a house and
nothing has happened and so for me the
starting point was somebody who has very
clearly spent a ton of time thinking
about the thing that they'd like to do
is not tap into the how but deeply tap
into the why so it forces you to take
imperfect action I agree with with what
you were saying about telling the story
like I think ultimately all of these
things that Dr o went through her drama
and debt and disease and depression and
divorce these are all part of her story
and she said the big one is divorce so
or the huge one was divorce so start
with that
and and tell us your story and tell us
how it impacted you in your life and
your career and tell us how you've
rebounded since and
it's in perfect action and it's
expecting to suck and it's a lot of the
things that we've talked about in this
entire show but the practice of starting
to create content around it you take a
camera you take your cell phone
and you press record and you post
and there's there will be a million
house that then don't get solved in that
first recording great
the next one you can make it a little
bit better and a little bit better and a
little bit better but you can tell that
she's thought about this for a long time
and a lot of people are stuck in this
trap of thinking about something for
years and then they still haven't done
the thing and so it's action it's your
story
figure out if you like if you like
videos you know if you'd like audio if
you like written where are your
strengths and just start creating
and the habit of creating will build
momentum because that's the biggest
thing that's just missing is like all of
these pent-up ideas and knowing that you
can serve and knowing that you're
capable and it's just sitting there and
if you're just at home on your couch it
never gets out into the world and so
it's tapping into the why this matters
so much so it drives you to a point of
frustration to just say screw it I'm
just gonna put something up and then
tomorrow do it again and tomorrow do it
again and then tomorrow and then the
house start to make more sense
then the house become useful
don't stress about the perfect thumbnail
until you have videos on your Channel
we're trying to plan like 18 steps ahead
and so just get it out and it's going to
suck at the beginning anyway and
nobody's watching anyway perfect
right my first video on YouTube only has
a ton of views because of now people
want to go back and see what the first
video was but it had three comments in a
year and it was my mom my my sister and
some random I had one comment in one
year of that video going up that wasn't
my family on that video and plenty of
videos still on my channel way back that
have no comments
and I just kept making
and over time I got better and with
mentorship and in you know programs like
Movie Makers or The Mastermind like you
can get there a lot faster and learn but
you don't need more learning yet like
it's the doing and then the learning to
complement the doing so you can do
better because learning learning
learning learn without execution
leads to zero results like there's so
many smart talented people who who just
never end up having an impact because
they're not creating and so if that's a
scenario for you know anybody watching
it's tapping into the why so you get
frustrated enough to say I don't care if
it sucks I'm gonna make it anyway
because this is so important because
people need this message right now she
wants to help professional women in
health care why does this have to happen
right now that in a month is too late
and six months is too late like you
already know you have a message you
already know that it's badly needed
palatophone press record speak from the
heart expect to suck post and move on to
the next one and then the house we come
to help you get stronger absolutely I
love it Evan absolutely yes yes I went I
went a little rant there it was kind of
ranty no I love it I love it and it's
like you got three comments who cares
you know what you should be caring about
is the fact that you are doing it for a
purpose and you're doing it because you
love it it's like what we talked about
earlier it's like your focus can't be on
being amazing or on you know it being
successful the focus really needs to be
on you loving what you do and you being
passionate about it right that has to be
your focus it's about your intention you
want to help people focus on that to use
that you wanting to help people that's
your first step how do you help people
get yourself out there get your message
out there start telling your story
that's great that's uh you know and then
it takes us back to the first question
through of getting started now I'm
starting to see a theme in our question
right oh we got one more also from the
Discord and by the way everybody if you
want to ask a question for a future show
that I do with q a and a special guest
uh we'll link up in the disc in the
description a link to a Discord if you
want to go there and ask questions so
last question comes from c j u j a
kazuja uh I'm about to start my channel
as well but don't really know how to
approach people on the street so we
could take it as uh actually approach
people on the street or just how do you
get your your channel started who's
somebody's you know does again he's
stuck in the hub I don't know how to do
this yeah no it's funny because just
this morning I had a DM from one of our
movement makers asking like oh how do
you get people on your show like what do
you do and I guess I'll answer this
question just based on what I do so I
had like my first show was with cash of
Khan who's the CEO of the DNA company
and honestly like when I try to figure
out you know approaching people on the
street it's more like
who do I follow that I enjoy following
as a person I like his content or for
Content you know like I have to actually
generally have an interest in who they
are or what they do that's kind of like
my step number one step number two is am
I engaging in their Community am I in
their ecosystem are they posting and I'm
responding I'm responding to their
stories I'm engaging in the comments I'm
engaging with other people in in their
Community right like not just responding
to their posts but responding to other
people's comments am I actually engaged
do I care so for me it's like I have to
really be authentically interested in
that person and actually want them on my
show because I'm curious I have
questions I'm trying to build a mindset
Mastery show and I'm trying to interview
the people who I think have a cheap
Mastery in their mindset in some form or
another and I want to bring them on to
feature them so that they can share
their genius with me and and the
audience and you really have to care
about you know who it is that you're
bringing on and you have to connect with
their message and what they're trying to
do so for me once I've connected with
certain people and I've been
consistently commenting and responding
and following them on social media and
their initiatives then I'll actually
send an email or a DM saying hey I love
what you do here's why right like you
can say you're so awesome and be super
superficial but guess what so is
everybody else right how are you going
to be different be authentic be yourself
right you're going to be different
because you're going to be you and
you're going to tell them what it is
that you enjoy about their content or
about them right and then you're going
to tell them a little bit about your
show and why you think that there's some
amazing alignment and that would help
you in your community but also them in
their community and I just think that if
you can approach people as authentically
as possible and be very interested and
curious in them and their mission then I
think most people will respond to you
right because you've put an effort and
and you're doing it from a good place
and you have good intentions behind it
and I just think that there's you will
win more than you'll lose when you're
actually invested in that person here's
what I do every time I'm I'm struggling
with a decision like this
um yeah it's a hug and a push
and depending on what I need I'll have a
little bit of both so the push is I want
to do difficult things scary difficult
heart you know the fact that if I was
struggling to go and talk to somebody
out on the street I would tell myself I
do difficult things the fact that it's
uncomfortable means I have to do it
that's the push that's the hard I'm Evan
Carmichael I want to be this kind of
person who does scary difficult hard
things and so I'm gonna do it because
that's who I want to be that's the push
the hug is tapping into the intention
and the service like why do you want to
talk to these people on the street
to make them look bad to make them look
like an idiot to trip them you know
hopefully not
if you're part of believe nation in our
Discord you better be you know trying to
serve the world that's what we do so
hopefully there's a service oriented
nature that you're trying to tell their
story you're trying to give them some
inspiration you're trying to find out
how they're doing like whatever the
there is a positive intent hopefully in
the work that you're doing and then that
positive intent it drives me to go do
the courageous thing and so some days I
need more of the hug than the push and
some days you need more the push than
the hug
uh but I use both to push me towards
doing that thing I remember we talked
about maulette there's an ax behind me
here
which which was a gift from Ed and Andy
their Partners in a group called The
arate Syndicate and I spoke at their
event was the last thing before the
world shutdown that I did and it was an
event they flew me out there put me up
in this private suite and all the guest
speakers were unknown like even the
speakers didn't know the other speakers
and when we got there the speaker list
was revealed and I was on there and
before me was David Goggins and after me
was Peyton Manning and David Goggins is
like the most intense human alive and
Peyton Manning is arguably the greatest
quarterback of all time and I'm sitting
there in the middle like what am I doing
here right like why am I here on stage
with these two amazing people
and then I realized well Ed came here to
ask me to talk about thought leadership
and like those two aren't what's Peyton
Manning going to share about how to be a
thought leader and get your message out
to the world right and so I can help and
so what I did was the push of I I want
to do difficult things but also the hug
of I've found people in the audience and
I looked at their looked at them in the
eye like from behind the curtain and
like I'm here to help her I'm here to
help him so it's not just me looking
good on stage but I'm here to serve in
the help and so if you're afraid of
approaching somebody on the street tap
into to both the push that you do
difficult things and this is the start
of your journey and that you're trying
to serve people whether it's the person
that you're talking to and or the
audience who eventually watch this video
that the world needs your gift the world
needs your magic and you need to get up
and go off and do it and stop
procrastinating and that requires you to
believe
mindset Mary it always comes back to
believing I agree I agree okay so guys
if you want to ask a question for for
the next q a show go to the Discord the
links in the description below mindset
Mary people want to find you where are
they going yes you can find me on
Instagram at mindset Mary all one word
I'd love to have you and I hope that my
content inspires you to believe in
yourself and what you're capable of
achieving in this lifetime go check her
out to see me coach Mary on how to get
more money in her business check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe we'll
see you there every day I work is every
day I'm like screaming on the inside
because it's like I should not be doing
this this is not what I want to be doing
I'm being pulled to something completely
different so every day becomes harder